we ask everybody what's your bitcoin
price prediction by the end of the year
oh my god
i uh you know i i try to stay out of the
prediction because look i've been i've
been holding man i haven't been hoddling
since 2013 so one of the i i think uh
with the last company we ended up doing
this giveaway with coinbase where
effectively we gave away 50 bitcoin i
hope everyone um this was in 2015. i
hope everybody kept it
i do you gave away 50 bitcoin in 2014.
it was 2015. 2015 gave away 50 bitcoin
for your company for what
so this was crazy this was actually back
in um
this was in september of 2015. i can try
to find this but um at the time coinbase
still a startup uh incompany could just
raise money and they uh bitcoin had
crashed in price i think it was around
200
uh per coin and coinbase was doing this
giveaway where it was a referral program
where if you referred somebody to sign
up um for coinbase
and they bought a hundred and one
dollars of bitcoin they would give you
the referrer 75 dollars our company at
the time was all about saving people
money
and so we reached out to coinbase to say
we've got lots of people
who love saving money we think
cryptocurrency is is fascinating as
great people should know about it
would you be comfortable um if we spl if
we split um the refunds if we said look
like you know you can instantly make
37.50 um if you buy if you buy a bitcoin
a few days later we'll get 75 we'll send
send you over half and that's it um and
a lot of people did you know it turned
out you know a lot of people they're
like sure let's go for it and and
whatever and so it ended up being i
think on the order of 50 bitcoin that um
that we're giving out so look i uh i
think bitcoin is is incredible um you
know beyond it to i think um you know
though though ramp doesn't doesn't um
you know today operate in the
cryptocurrency space i i think we watch
it closely we think it's fascinating and
look if it becomes a great way to
whether it's to hold or or even um a
mechanism to help companies be more
efficient that's what we're about and
focused on and we'll keep our eyes on it
i just love it just to confirm you've
been holding bitcoin since 2013.
all
right
john is our resident like wonder man
he's like
[Music]
there for a second all right well listen
thank you so much for coming and doing
this this is absolutely fantastic
everyone go to ramp.com
pomp go check it out we're uh we're big
fans here and i think that you guys will
enjoy it as well
uh other than that if uh if you want to
make personal investments go to sofi.com
they've been fantastic partners for the
show
they allow you to do everything from buy
pre-ipo stocks you can buy uh bitcoin
right now if you go and you buy 10
bitcoin they'll give you ten dollars for
free
anything else
not from me
joe's scheming right now i don't know
what he's going to do
when the video shuts off joe's going to
say
i was just laughing and someone said
something that they would they say no no
listen no secrets around here it's not
in the chat it was a text message oh
don't worry about it all right we
appreciate you guys watching we'll uh
we'll be back tomorrow we've got will
clemente we're working on there's one
other person who's here in miami right
now who uh maybe we'll get him to come
on man he said he's got a new mic new
sale
will does say he does have a new mic
he's got a new background he's got a new
video like the guy better show up at
rolls royce tomorrow
because that's what he that's what he
said on twitter so we appreciate you
guys watching make sure you're
subscribed to the channel make sure you
like the video and we will see you all
tomorrow thanks so much what's up guys
bang bang thanks so much for watching
the best business show today if we're
gonna be the best business show we
obviously need the best partner that's
why the exclusive sponsor the best
business show is sofi they're an
all-in-one platform that allows you to
invest in all kinds of different assets
including stocks etfs crypto ipos and
they even have an automated investing
function if that's your thing so before
we start getting after it again make
sure that you go download sofi you get
an invest account and when you make your
first crypto trade regardless of what
you buy they'll give you 10 in bitcoin
for free it's that simple head on over
to sofi.com to get started today thanks
so much for watching and i hope you come
back and watch more the best business
show tomorrow
[Music]